could you back into Santa's we'll start
with the shortcomings of trump he's 76
years old he has no ability to control
his mouth or his typing fingers he has
no sort of actual plan to win I mean he
literally complained in 2020 that he was
robbed of the election through voter
fraud but no one will ask him a simple
question how do you plan to unrob the
election in 2024 he's wildly unpopular
with women he has an approval rating
last I checked in the 20s and by the
available data he will probably
underperform how he performed in 2020.
saying to millions of people yeah you
voted for me in 2016. then you voted
against me in 2020 and I want you to
switch back and vote for me that's not
even switching Minds once that's
switching mines twice that's super
difficult DeSantis is extremely
meticulous about how he approaches
politics when he focuses it on an issue
he really focuses he is good at actually
governing the dirty little secret about
Florida is to really well governed state
right we have all the cultural War stuff
that makes the national media but the
stuff that doesn't make the national
media is that when there's a hurricane
we're rebuilding Bridges within like a
day right that the problems actually get
solved here that distance is brought
down crime rates dramatically that he
offered police officer a ten thousand
dollar stipend to move into the state